♪ "If" and "then"
are two regular words ♪
♪ that work together
exquisitely. ♪
♪ If I can show you
by singing this song, ♪
♪ then you'll
remember it easily. ♪
♪ I'll give you a tool
that starts with a rule ♪
♪ to tell you what the next
thing you do ought to be. ♪
♪ Now listen carefully! ♪
♪ If the weather
is sunny... ♪
♪ ...then wear a cap. ♪
♪ If you want to go hiking... ♪
♪...then get a map. ♪
♪ If you picture
these two words... ♪
♪ ...then it's
an easy decision. ♪
♪ If there was ever a time
to get down, ♪
♪ then this is one. ♪
♪ If the music is off,
then turn it on. ♪
♪ If the music is on,
then turn it up. ♪
♪ If the music is up,
then hit the floor. ♪
♪ And if you're on the floor,
then dance. ♪
♪ "If" and "then"
are two regular words ♪
♪ but what a marvelous job
they do. ♪
♪ If there's a part
with an "if" at the start, ♪
♪ find out if
what's in that part is true. ♪
♪ Now wasn't that fun? ♪
♪ You're practically done... ♪
♪...because the "then"
part tells you ♪
♪ what you ought to do. ♪
♪ Now you can try it too. ♪
♪ If it's finally
snack time... ♪
♪ ...then have some fruit. ♪
♪ If today
is your birthday... ♪
♪ ...then give a toot. ♪
[HORN HONKS]
♪ If you follow my method... ♪
♪ ...then it will give you
the know-how. ♪
♪ If there was ever
a time to get down, ♪
♪ then it's right now. ♪
♪ If the music is off,
then turn it on. ♪
♪ If the music is on,
then turn it up. ♪
♪ If the music is up,
then hit the floor. ♪
♪ And if you're on the floor,
then dance. ♪
♪ If you're on the floor,
then dance, dance, dance.♪
♪ Woah, dance now. ♪
♪ If you're on the floor,
then dance, dance, dance. ♪
♪ Helpsters! ♪
♪